Okay Michael so you, let's make certain that
you really grasp this concept of weak learning okay?
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, here's a little quiz that I put together to test your knowledge.
So, here's the, here's the deal. I've got a little matrix here, it's a
little table, and across the top. Are
three different hypotheses. So, hypothesis one, hypothesis
two, and hypothesis three. So your entire
hypothesis base consists only of these three hypothesis,
hypotheses. Got it?
>> Got it.
>> Okay, your entire instance space consists entirely of
only four examples; X1, X2, X3, and X4. Got it?
>> Got it.
>> I have an X in a square, if that particular hypothesis does not get the
correct label for that particular instance, and I
have a green check mark if that particular
hypothesis does in fact get the right label for that
example. So, in this case hypothesis one gets examples 2, 3,
and 4 correct. But gets example one wrong, while hypothesis
three gets one in four correct, but two and three incorrect.
>> I see. So, there's no hypothesis that gets everything right.
>> Right.
>> So does that mean that we don't have a weak
learner, because then there's some distributions for which any given hypothesis
is going to get things wrong.
>> Maybe. Maybe not. Let's see. Here's what I want you to do. I want
you to come up with the distribution over
the 4 different examples, such that a learning
algorithm that has to choose between one of
those 3 hypotheses will in fact be able
to find that does better than chance. That
is, has an expected error greater than half.
>> Okay. Then if you can do that, I want
you to see if you can find a distribution which might not exist,
such that if you have that distribution
over the four examples, a learning algorithm
that only looked at h1, h2 and h3 would not be
able to return one of them that has an expected error greater than half.
>> So greater than half in this case would mean three out of four, correct?
Oh no, no. Oh, you're using, you want to
use that definition that you, that actually took
into consideration the distribution.
>> Exactly. That's the whole point. If you, if you always need to
have some distribution over your examples to
really know what your expected error is.
>> Alright. And if there is no such evil distribution, should I just fill in
zeroes in all those boxes? Yes, all zeros means no such distribution. You can do
it in either case. So if you put in all zeros you're saying no such
distribution exists. But otherwise it should add
up to one down each of the columns.
>> It had better add up to one.
>> Alright, I think I
can give that a shot. Okay, go.